not to decide the game okay oh stop it
not to decide the game they're running
people over
he gave them did he run him over or did
he sell it
so that was the energy we saw of dame
lillard put some respect on his name
back-to-back 50-point games and portland
now is in the driver's seat
to get into the play-in game they are
sitting now at the eighth seed
and after the game we heard from lillard
and everybody else about his performance
and the fact that portland is five and
two and looking at the lakers as a
possible first round match-up
today you joined will chamberlain as one
of the only two players in league
history to have three
60-point games in the same season i'm
curious your thoughts on that
accomplishment
first of all i'm happy to be in that
type of company you know that's
an honor um and i'm also happy that it
came
you know two of the three came in the
winning effort and you know tonight
couldn't have been better timing for
that type of game i had the best seat in
the house i was i was front row
and whenever somebody has it going like
that i mean all you can do is just let
them go
nobody wanted to come into this bubble
and and make the playoffs more than dame
his leadership uh obviously his game
speaks for himself but
uh you know he's bringing the team along
with them
the shot that lillard took from
what 40 feet you know into the shot
clock gets the back room bounces
straight up in the air and goes in
i've never seen a shot like that ever i
mean
that was unbelievable
i kept watching it because i was like i
think that's going to go in and
it dropped in but uh you know i think
that was
you know my cousin you know rest in
peace chef b i think that was him
dropping that in for me
i probably said about 20 please like
completely like
repeatedly i just wanted uh
it wasn't meant for us to lose when that
shot went in
all right let's take another look oh i
love this game
i think it's very apropos that he is now
tied for allen iverson with the eighth
most
50 point games in his career because
this is what this blazers team is
feeling right now one guy is putting him
on his back
how long can this last can can he really
go in and let's say i'm looking way into
the future
they get past the playing game can can
one guy and i know
it's about everybody but can he put the
fear into the lakers
allen iverson did it oh i don't know one
game
he did have fifteen experience to the
lake i ain't saying he's anything he's
gonna win the series i said he put
through
it to the lakers and the way he's
playing right now one game he messed up
history but it's cool
15-1 yeah because they were going four
four four four yeah the wings tyron lou
go ahead i believe i believe dame could
do this yeah but and here's the thing
right cj had a tough night right and
apparently the reports are he's a
fractured back
i mean that's that's correct that's out
of this mind if he still played with
that but when you got someone like melo
and that's what they didn't have last
year if dame if cj had off night didn't
have anybody else mellow tonight
10-17 scores 26 points that's what this
team was missing last year so
dame dame can do this this is dame like
he did it all year this is not a fluke
this ain't for the bubble
dane was doing this before we shut this
yeah two other 60 points so this
this is dame dollar the only unfortunate
thing
is playoffs is going to slow down a
little bit
they're probably going to double and
triple teemo make them get rid of the
ball
and in order for them to play like that
he has to do like this every night
he can do it don't get me wrong you can
get 40 50 you let him go but
especially they play the lakers i didn't
realize that he would make him get rid
of the ball until you said it
at i think it was pregame he doesn't
even look tired after these games
listen he listen he's ready he stayed
ready you know he
he knew something we didn't know you
know a lot of guys were putting out
pictures of how cut up they were but
when we see him in real life photoshop
like a mug
[Laughter]
i do want to say this since he missed
that free throw
against the clippers dame lillard is 33
for 34 from the line i know that you
have some video that you want to take us
through
what what do we see from daylily i let i
can't i can handle any more dame willing
outside of confidence you know for him
if they do double you you do have mello
but right here he feels like he can get
wherever he wants
he can score at any level here's the
pick-and-roll which the big sitting back
hesitation
he's sitting back stop he went right by
that up he was up he went
okay he'll have a chance what about here
where's he going where's that first step
no he chill backwards he'll be in the
studio with us
but yeah but exactly but right here he
knows
like i can i can make this you know and
and that's the thing
a con he has to stay confident which
eyes
you see those eyes right there
absolutely yeah anger
and that's what i'm saying so even if cj
is injured
and can't go you still have mellow so if
they double
you can rely on mello's experience and
ability to score
but i still think they're going to need
a healthy cj or
another other and that would probably be
gary trent gary trent's been great 11
points tonight one of six from three
but nurkic has been great we do have a
tweet from nurkic it's hard to stay
mellow on this one bra
dame willard sorry not sorry